we're back with senior economist heading
further mr. Firpo was that above all the
burst in China or was it something else
I think it's just a correction of over
optimistic expectations in the market so
I don't think it's a bursting bubble
because the situation the economy in
China is still backed by fundamentals
and and you base that on on on
experience I've been there in two in
China and I've observed that obviously
China is on a great transition to more
sustained sustainable growth and yeah
fostering investments in education and
infrastructure research and development
so China is seeking for new sources of
growth so you're confident China's on
the right path and that China shouldn't
be at the top of traders worry lists I
think so at least in the medium term and
the short run their still panic in the
market but I'm quite sure that the
Chinese government is able to manage
this panic and where does that put China
and Russia the other big question marks
at the moment as far as emerging
economies go I'm much more concerned
about Brazil and Russia of the problems
there are much more or a deeper and need
more political adjustment strengthening
the institution's been in China ok so
both Brazil and Russia rather at the top
of traders worry lists as opposed to
China and and confidence as far as
China's path ahead goes heading propa
thank you very much good to have you on
the show income